foreign
the Philippines shares with other
nations of the developing world the
visible pressure of population growth
industrialization and a top layer of
commercial modernism have made its
cities like cities everywhere large loud
crowded with people and vehicles
contending for the same inadequate
allocation of space and natural
resources
there are moreover special
characteristics in this land to explain
the magnitude of its recent growth
it seems a land of the very young
almost 45 percent of all Filipinos are
under 15 years of age
Family Ties Are unusually strong and
even in the worst of circumstances it is
hard for a Filipino to avoid regarding a
large family as somehow better than a
small one
it is a nation of devoutly religious
people where the Catholic church and its
most traditional pro-natalist form has
broad influence
still within this unlikely atmosphere
have grown up A diversity of population
efforts one of them employing the very
strengths of the society love of family
and Home in furtherance of population
goals is that of the indigenous church
called iglesiani Cristo
one of its ministers explains the
rationale behind the program the Church
of Christ
Ina Christo
is aware of the fact
that there is a
tremendous growth
population
as administrators of the church
we are most concerned and interested
in the
welfare about the poor elements
of the church
because our concerns is not simply to
look into
the spiritual welfare of the members
but also
after the material aspect of life
every family is responsible for the
future welfare
other children
we have explained to them
the benefits of family planning
and we really were satisfied with the
tremendous response
among the members
[Music]
this is the church in catanduanis an
island off the coast of Luzon where a
population of farmers and fishermen live
the most modest of lives and offer an
unusual laboratory for the program of
this distinctively Filipino Church
founded in 1914 it has had an almost
phenomenal growth not only in the
Philippines but in other areas of Asia
Europe and North America
it is notable principally for its strong
concern for social remediation its
cohesiveness and the discipline of its
members
[Music]
foreign
Family Planning campaign in 1973 and
within three years had enlisted some 280
000 users
Family Planning became the theme of
sermons in churches throughout the
country
thus the church made Family Planning in
one step not only acceptable to
Christian doctrine but the Keystone of a
broad program of social betterment
is an already existing delivery system
for Family Planning services
are such local structures in every
country they are ready to be
imaginatively used to expand the
population effort
the newest and most spectacularly
successful element of the Family
Planning program is the sterilization
campaign in which mobile teams fan out
from Manila through parishes all over
the country
it is a markedly informal project
responding on short notice to appeals
from whatever church has assembled a
large enough number of candidates who
have made their voluntary decision for
sterilization
informality aside it is also a
thoroughly scientific program
instruments gloves drapes and all other
needed materials are packed for field
use with sterilization procedures as
precise as though the work were to be
done in the headquarters Clinic
in this case the mobile team of doctors
nurses and general assistants Travels by
Van to the coast vents by ferry to the
island from which this newest appeal has
come
[Music]
yeah
here as in most rural regions they will
make their base in the church compound
you could
the arrival of the mobile team van is an
occasion for cheerful interest on the
part of the whole Community not only the
male candidates for vasectomy but their
women and children
[Music]
here they will use the administrative
office of the church as an operating
room
such Arrangements lend themselves to
vasectomy procedures
ligations which are growing in
popularity among women of the Church
community requiring more medically
sophisticated setting
every effort is made to bring women who
want many laparotomies the most common
sterilization operation for women to the
nearest available Health Center
[Applause]
already minister
this is the third visit of the
serialization team and the satisfied
customers have been the strongest
motivators
there is a high degree of mutual support
among the brothers and sisters as they
are known to each other for the
sterilization procedure sterilization
Carolina Gabrielle who was her husband
Melania administers the program for the
Iglesia ni Cristo will be the surgeon
today
before the first operation there will be
a talk explaining exactly what vasectomy
is and is not and what the patient may
expect in the course of the operation
and subsequent to it
the atmosphere is visibly informal
evangular
in its way the church is an extended
family
even such serious considerations as a
vasectomy are treated in simple familial
terms
the doctor knows that the men have
chosen to have this operation
voluntarily but she is anxious that they
not have any doubts as to its nature its
permanence and its potential effect upon
their future lives
in country Tagalog with pepperings of
Spanish and English she explains the
male reproductive system in terms her
listeners will recognize
she confronts the most common fear that
vasectomy is a form of emasculation by
assuring them that it will not interfere
in any way with their sex life nor
diminish their virility
thank you
fishermen and Farmers respond
comfortably to her earthy explanations
they are close to Nature and accustomed
to calling things by their natural names
[Laughter]
it's firm there is much serious talk
about the importance of informed consent
and the Iglesia ni Cristo has been
punctilious in its demand that its
people be fully informed and positively
consenting
they may be humanly apprehensive about
it as about any surgery but the
breeziness of the presentation is
reassuring
this is no official demand upon them
with a weight of government orders
behind it
they have no reason to fear Authority
the church is their family which brings
them all together
and they are convinced of its concern
for their well-being
oh
adito one here and one here
[Applause]
a vasectomy is a relatively simple
outpatient procedure
normally the only discomfort is related
to the injection which numbs the
operating area and that is minor
[Applause]
the patient will have a few days of
soreness and diminished activity then
after an interval of contraceptive
protection to ensure that all remaining
sperm have been expelled and he is
certain to be sterile he and his wife
are free to resume full relationship
without any fear of unwanted pregnancy
[Applause]
the men of these islands are wholly
masculine by nature and by cultural
tradition
they have worked hard since childhood
and most of them expect to work hard as
long as they live
they are comparatively poor people as
rice farmers and fishermen and their
families are likely to be the world over
has given them something of value a
perception of Brotherhood among
themselves and of kinship with men and
women on other islands and other
continents
armed with this sense of security and
responsibility more than fourteen
thousand men and women have chosen
surgical contraception in the three
years of the program
in a country where sterilization was
once thought wholly unacceptable this is
a remarkable record
because they are Islanders they know
that they are already enjoying the
fruits of all the land they will ever
have their boundary on all sides is the
sea
but then we all are dwellers on an
island in a sea of space whose resources
are finite and fast diminishing
indeed we are all Islanders
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]